Russia's President Putin goes to Iran
this morning seeking support for his war
on Ukraine and according to the White
House new drones as Russia steps up its
rocket attacks on Ukraine the human cost
of the fighting is growing Holly
Williams has more from Kiev the
Ukrainian capital
[Music]
s
another mother caressing a casket you I
didn't have a chance to kiss you goodbye
she says
Ukrainian Fighters have been celebrated
for their bravery in the face of
Vladimir Putin's Invasion but it's left
this country counting its dead and mired
in grief
Ukraine's defiant resistance continues
aided by new more powerful weapons from
the US and its allies
but make no mistake this war is costing
thousands of Ukrainian lives and there's
no end in sight this war threatens to
just devolve into a grinding War of
Attrition Colonel Andy Milburn served in
the Marines doing tours of Duty in Iraq
and Somalia now he's in Ukraine training
Frontline troops with a group of other
retired U.S servicemen we have only five
days typically if we're lucky two weeks
maximum to bring a guy who has never
fired a weapon never even handled a
weapon to where now he is in the front
line they're under you know Russian
Artillery fire so a lot of these guys
getting killed and wounded without
without a chance really to do anything
draped in Ukraine's blue and gold flag
this Soldier was buried with full
military honors
the cost of Ukraine's courage is being
paid in blood
[Music]
Ukraine's government won't tell us
exactly how many of its soldiers have
been killed but in May President
Vladimir zielinski said his country was
losing between 60 and 100 troops every
day Gail
oh those numbers are hard to hear thank
you very much Holly Williams reporting
from Ukraine